keratinous pursued it's been becoming
Umezu zester and PGP audience
my name is Tobuscus won't die sneeze
might stop
oh my god I can't believe I finally made
it to YouTube High School
I'm so excited to make videos I think
this will make a great 200 part series I
love making videos I love it so much
God well then I better hurry to get
started ah I'm again I'm so sorry for
bumping into you guys I totally didn't
see you how dare you you've been touched
by an impure don't you know who we are
guys go easy on him I think he's new
shut up shut your mouth patty pie no one
touches me
oh [ __ ] that's right Allah now apologize
guys please just do this for me all
right fine I'm sorry I'm so sorry that's
okay
since you're new I will let you go for
now
the but you should know the way to grow
subscribers it's to pretend that you're
friends with everyone so give me a
compliment
ah okay you have a you have a yes you
have a face yes it looks like there is
some potential in you after all I'm sure
you get medicines crabbers all right
let's get out of here don't worry about
those guys they're really nice once you
get to know them hey we we we seem
really similar unite blah blah blah you
have really nice hair I like your outfit
Brooke you smell like chocolate I wish
we're best friends
um yeah we should totally be friends you
know what I'll show you rent school
follow me nnnn every book that I read
every bit a develop relative I'm fed up
ba ba ba ba ba better than up another so
yeah this is our inside of our school
pretty cool yeah can't wait to make
videos hey what's over there
what is this that's the door to the
other side trust me you don't want to go
there that's where the people in control
are but no punch we must go there
subscribers to catch a bad ffffff ever
huh I wonder why he was so uptight about
this do it what could possibly be inside
I'm so curious I'm gonna go check it out
we need ideas we haven't had a good
update on YouTube since 2011
I wonder what's going down over here
the next person who doesn't give me a
good idea will be fire what about Google
Plus Larry we stopped using at people
didn't like it people already have
Facebook accounts the weather that
Google - oh my god how will we possibly
get good ideas bananas what is this
and that's Toby Turner shot he has a lot
of subscribing what the [ __ ] is a
subscriber bananas tell me why does his
man keep saying bananas well you see I
think he wants us to invest in bananas
my god
that's the best idea we ever had who is
this man give us more we're desperate
toilet paper oh my god Lisa are you
writing this [ __ ] down trying to pay for
one else tables tables oh my god
pineapples pineapples pineapples oh my
god we're gonna be rich again alright I
think that we need to keep this man with
us
yes our main [ __ ] from now on what's
his name's Shane Dawson was it Toby
chatted Sam ffff ever man show me what
are you doing here you're not supposed
to be these people they're dangerous
bananas oh my god what did they do to
you
bananas bananas chubby tell me no we
have to get out of here these people are
they're changing you come on we gotta
get up we need ideas
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
mmm-mmm-mmm Brock Tommy I can't believe
they do this to you very nice
bananas yes Jimmy bananas come on hurry
we got to go better than a peppermint ah
bananas bananas oh oh oh oh don't let
him fall down there's a huge lava pit
down there
Jimmy no hang on chubby don't worry I'll
get you tell me you don't know how much
you mean to me
banana yes Toby banana you know you were
always there for me and you were a huge
inspiration for me to get started with
my channel but now look at you
banana you've changed you've changed
Toby but I would take care of you from
now on don't worry it's gonna be okay
if you don't let them go we will cancel
your YouTube account
what well [ __ ] that [ __ ] then better put
ba ba ba ba hang in there Toby you're in
safe hands now banana
he's falling no what'd you say
nah well of course you did what'd you
say banana met Itza for the best of
course it is what you say no there's
gotta be happening don't worry boss
we can still savage some of his remains
get him up there
oh babe oh but oh how is he looking he
has about a 75% chance of survival but
half his brain went missing he lost his
ability to speak and his lover parts
it's not a problem as long as he can
keep coming up with ideas gone Oh
bananas bananas bananas bananas bananas
bananas bananas
goedendag
audience do this Saturday
you Tyler Oakley take this man to be
your lawful wedded husband I do and you
tell rookies take this man to be your
lawful wedded husband yes well and I
pronounce you husband and